ya tenemos un montón de vídeos sobre la
idea del teorema a mí déjame ponerlo
aquí teorema del valor medio valor medio
y bueno aunque tenemos ya un montón de
vídeos sobre esta idea
quiero repasar un poquito porque quiero
ver cómo se conecta esta idea del
teorema del valor medio que estudiamos
en el cálculo diferencial con la idea
del valor promedio de una función usando
integrales definidas así que el teorema
del valor medio que nos decía nos dice
que si tenemos una función f
voy a ponerlo aquí que si tenemos una
función f
la cual es continua continua en el
intervalo y vamos a ponerlo así en el
intervalo cerrado a be ok tengo una
función continua en este intervalo y
además que es diferenciable en el
intervalo abierto a como p déjame
ponerlo así es diferenciable
se hable ok en el intervalo abierto
ok en cómo ve y ojo estamos tomando un
intervalo abierto es decir la derivada
está definida en este intervalo abierto
no necesariamente tiene que ser
diferenciable en las fronteras pero lo
que sí es que tiene que ser derivable
entre las fronteras y bueno si tenemos
estos dos entonces nosotros sabemos lo
siguiente entonces nosotros sabemos que
existe algún valor o algún número
pensemos mejor en algún número así que
lo voy a escribir existe existe ok
un número número número que vamos a
llamar ser ok
existe un número c tal que
y que ok y eso es muy importante va a
ocurrir lo siguiente si existe entre
estas dos fronteras así que luego
escribe así es menor que sé que es menor
que ven ok sé existe entre estas dos
fronteras y y esto es muy importante y
además se cumple y esto es muy
importante porque es la parte central de
este teorema además se va a cumplir que
la derivada de la función en ese punto o
lo puedes ver como la pendiente de la
recta tangente en ese punto
y esto lo voy a poner así como f prima o
que deseen esto va a ser exactamente
igual y lo puedes ver como la tasa de
cambio en ese intervalo o lo podemos ver
como la pendiente que éste genera entre
estos dos puntos finales y bueno la
pendiente que se genera entre estos dos
puntos finales a la podemos ver como el
cambio en james y para eso vamos a
pensar en él
dv ok esto - bueno pues efe a efe de a
ok esto a su vez está dividido entre
bueno pues ve - a ver - a de lujo y
bueno realmente profundizamos mucho más
en este tema en el primer curso de
cálculo pero sólo recordando vamos a
analizarlo un poco de manera visual
porque creo que es mucho más intuitivo
si lo analizamos de una manera visual
justo por aquí así que déjame dibujar
aquí dos ejes tengo aquí uno de mis ejes
aquí tengo otro de mis ejes déjenme
poner que este es uno de mis ejes este
va a ser otro de mis ejes y bueno voy a
decir que por aquí tengo a ok por aquí
voy a tener ave y por aquí también tengo
a mi función haciendo algo interesante
mi función hace algo más o menos así ok
y bueno entonces voy a decir que aquí
tengo a efe de am por aquí tengo a efe y
bueno si habemos queremos fijar en justo
lo que tenemos aquí en esta expresión
que tenemos aquí
bueno pues creo que te descuenten lo
siguiente a efe - y fedea es a esta
distancia que tengo aquí esta distancia
que tengo aquí es fpv - efe de am ok y
bueno de menos a es justo la distancia
que tengo de aquí hasta acá ok y bueno
si te das cuenta lo que nos estamos
fijando realmente es en la pendiente de
la recta que se genera entre estos dos
puntos la pendiente de la recta que va
de este punto hasta este otro punto
justo este de aquí y bueno justo lo que
nos dice el teorema del valor medio es
que existe una si existe enlace en ese
intervalo y déjame ponerlo con este
color el cual su pendiente de su recta
tangente es exactamente igual a esta
pendiente de esta recta que tenemos en
azul es decir por aquí tenemos aún hace
justo esté por aquí base
un valor para hacer el cual va a cumplir
que si nos fijamos en la pendiente de su
recta tangente
es exactamente igual que la pendiente de
esta recta que cruza todo este intervalo
y bueno puede ser solamente estas o
pueden existir varias pero lo que sí
sabemos es que al menos existe una sem y
ojo estamos hablando de una función
continua y diferenciable en este
intervalo ahora seguramente cuando tú
ves esto algo de ti te recuerda o
encuentras alguna semejanza con la
fórmula o la definición del valor
promedio de una función y vamos a
recordarla el valor promedio ok voy a
ponerlo así promedio de una función esto
lo definimos como 1 / b menos a ok esto
que a su vez multiplica a la integral a
la integral definida desde a hasta b ok
efe de x de x de x y bueno date cuenta
que aquí tenemos uno / b - y por aquí
también tenemos b - como denominador y
seguramente esto te va a parecer muy
interesante porque aquí estamos hablando
de una derivada y aquí estamos hablando
de una integral entonces parece que
podemos conectar estas dos ideas y bueno
seguramente tal vez lo primero que te
salte la vista es que entonces podemos
encontrar una forma de escribir este
numerador que tengo aquí como esta
expresión que tengo justo aquí y de
hecho te encargo que pases el vídeo y
pienses en cómo reescribir este
numerador como esta integral que tengo
aquí y te voy a dar una pista date
cuenta que aquí tenemos fx cuando por
acá necesitamos f prima de x así que
tenga algo que pienses en esto por
un rato
y bueno regresando una vez más esta
parte de acá podemos escribir la de la
siguiente manera y pon mucha atención
esto lo podemos ver como la integral
definida de a hasta b de f prima de x de
x ok
y es que piensas un poco si tomamos la
anti derivada de f priva de x solamente
nos quedaría fx y si eso lo evaluamos
primero en b nos va a quedar
efe db y a esto lo tenemos que tomar la
diferencia con la función evaluada nam
es decir etcétera y bueno claro a esto
hay que dividirlo a esto hay que
dividirlo entre b menos a ok y de lujo
esto se empieza a poner interesante
porque una forma de pensarlo es la
siguiente debe de existir una sem que
cuando evalúa su derivada en cm
esto es lo mismo que el valor promedio
de la derivada
o podemos pensarlo de la siguiente
manera otra forma de verlo es que si
bautizamos a una nueva función y déjame
ponerlo con este nuevo color si
bautizamos a una función como gtx igual
a efe prima de x a efe prima de x
entonces vamos a estar muy cerca de lo
que tenemos justo aquí y para eso
déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla y
vamos a escribirlo de la siguiente
manera esto que tenemos aquí lo podemos
ver como gdc como gdc como gdc y bueno
esto por la definición porque gdc es lo
mismo que f prima de s y bueno esto es
exactamente lo mismo que uno entre
venenosa y lo voy a poner con este mismo
color 1 / b - ah ok esto que a su vez
multiplica a la integral desde a hasta b
ok d efe prima de x de x pero f prima de
x es lo mismo que de x por lo tanto lo
voy a escribir como
x de x esto por la definición de gx cdc
es igual a 1 entre b menos a que
multiplica a la integral desde esta vez
deje de x de x y esto es por nuestra
definición de gx de lujo y es que esta
es otra forma de pensar lo que de hecho
es otra forma de ver el teorema del
valor medio y por cierto a esto le
llaman el teorema del valor medio déjame
ponerlo así el teorema del valor medio
pero para integrales para integrales
integrales de lujo que bueno
esencialmente lo que nos va a decir es
que si tenemos una función de x gdx que
sea continua continua ok en el intervalo
cerrado a b ok entonces debe de existir
anp y déjame ponerlo así entonces
entonces existe c
entonces existe cm ok y estás en am es
tal que obtiene la propiedad que se
cumple kg evaluada en sí es lo mismo que
esto de aquí y que es estoy aquí
nuestro valor promedio de la función
entonces déjame ponerlo así entonces
existe ese tal que ok tal que han de ser
g
de c es exactamente igual que g promedio
que promedio es decir el valor promedio
de la función pero bueno en general lo
que quería contarte es la definición del
teorema del valor medio para integrales
este de kim y que te dieras cuenta de
que es muy parecido claro sólo con una
anotación distinta al teorema del valor
medio que vimos en cálculo diferencial y
bueno también quiero que te des cuenta
que tiene una diferencia pequeña en su
interpretación cuando nosotros nos
fijamos en la interpretación y déjeme
subir para que la pantalla de el teorema
del valor medio hablando de cálculo
diferencial entonces pensábamos en un
valor sem en este punto que tiene la
cualidad de que la pendiente de su recta
tangente es la misma que la tasa
promedio de cambio en este intervalo
aunque la pendiente promedio en este
intervalo esté visto desde la
perspectiva del cálculo diferencial
hablando de pendientes
cuando lo vemos o lo pensamos en un
contexto en el cálculo integral
bueno pues realmente lo que estamos
hablando es del valor promedio de la
función
estamos hablando de promedios es decir
existe una sed tal que el valor de la
función evaluada en ese punto ce es
igual al valor promedio de la función
otra forma de verdad sería y déjenme
poner aquí un pequeño dibujo si yo lo
dibujó algo así tengo aquí mis dos ejes
voy a tener un eje por aquí otro eje por
acá y voy a decir que este es mi eje y
este es mi eje x ok y bueno voy a poner
por aquí a mi función de x y voy a
suponer que esa función que de x es esta
que tengo aquí voy a dibujarla algo así
ok
aquí tengo mi función g de x y lo voy a
poner si bien es igual a gtx y bueno
nosotros queremos fijarnos en un
intervalo en el intervalo que va desde a
ok hasta be ok vamos a ponerlo por aquí
y no voy a fijar en este intervalo por
acá ok
y por acá ok y entonces nosotros ya
vimos cómo calcular nuestro valor
promedio que tal vez sea a déjame
cambian de color me gusta este de por
aquí este de por aquí va a ser el
promedio ok y realmente lo que nos dice
el teorema del valor medio para
integrales es que debe de existir una c
en este caso va a ser esta de aquí tal
que cuando evaluamos hace en esta
función a dejar el poner así cuando
evaluamos hace en esta función g nos dan
el valor promedio gdc toma el valor de g
promedio y claro donde ésta se está en
este intervalo